honeymoon in a wine sounds like a dream
come true right well it became one
couple's worst nightmare when they ended
up abandoned at Sea that's right
Elizabeth Webster and Alexander burkel
spent their honeymoon in Hawaii back in
2021 and they are now plaintiffs in a
multi-million dollar lawsuit on their
trip they embarked on a five-hour
snorkeling tour with a company called
Sail Maui the couple spent roughly an
hour at the first diving spot and the
lawsuit states that the water got more
turbulent as they tried to swim back to
their boat and despite giving distress
signals The Newlywed couple claims the
boat sailed off leaving them stranded in
the ocean a half a mile away from Land
44 people went on that tour and crew
members allegedly performed three head
counts before leaving the diving spot
the lawsuit says that two of those head
counts came out to 42 people with a
third round incorrectly counting 44
people the couple said they eventually
reached the shore on a different Island
this is one that tour guides worn could
have shallow reefs luckily local
residents on that Island helped them
return to Maui safely the couple is
seeking 5 million dollars in Damages
from the tour company citing gross
negligence and intentional infliction of
emotional distress so Brian you think
this couple has a strong case or are
they uh you know out to sea with this
lawsuit so to speak yeah well Jesse in
my mind it's what happened on the boat
when they were missing that really
strengthens their case as you mentioned
it's the counting I would think it's
just simple math and if it's hard well
you already don't have shoes on so use
your toes to count too you get to 42
twice and then you get to 44. also we're
hearing that people actually said hey
you're missing two people so it comes
down to Industry standards and whether
or not they followed it appropriately
but the simple fact that they just were
missing I mean my wife is a master diver
I had to talk to her about this and
they're like yeah no this is a pretty no
duh thing you make sure you get it right
and you create the systems to make sure
you always get it right so you don't
have things like this uh I think it's a
slam Zone case I don't think we're gonna
ever see this at trial I think they're
gonna settle before it even gets there
any defenses that the torque company can
assert in this case very few I think
Brian's right it is a good case for them
but I think some of the defenses look
there are two causes of action here one
is gross negligence the other is
intentional infliction of emotional
distress no question gross negligence I
mean it means they were Reckless and
they had disregard for their lives
basically and I think that the couple
will be able to show that the other is a
little bit more difficult but it's one
of my favorite torts intentional
infliction of emotional distress that
means it's based on the wording
intentional they had to intentionally
leave them out there and cause their
emotional distress no doubt they're
going to be able to show they have
emotional distress they'll have to have
medical records Etc and I think it's
easy to show that it caused that
distress but was it intentional I'm sure
they didn't mean to leave them there
well I think here's the important thing
to remember this is you know a terrible
situation for them thank goodness
they're okay because this could have
ended up much worse than we're reporting
right now and in North Carolina is
facing several charges including
reckless driving after almost hitting
two children with his car take a look at
this very scary video they started to
cross the street to the bus when the car
speeds towards them swerving at the very
last second to miss them North Carolina
State Highway Patrol arrested Joshua
Graham Padgett Jr just days after the
near Miss police say Not only was
Padgett charged with reckless driving
and passing a stop school bus but he's
also facing a charge for driving with a
revoked license that is not good
and when we come back a rap concert in
New York leaves two people dead and one
fighting for her life how on Earth did
this happen we're breaking down what we
know so far
[Music]
welcome back everybody we finish off
today's show in Rochester New York where
a hip-hop concert on Sunday night ended
in a deadly Stampede Memphis rappers
glorilla and finesse two times hosted
the show at Rochester's Main Street
Armory the venue can hold up to 5 000
guests in their main event space and
after the artists wrapped up their
performance guests suddenly started to
Surge towards the venue exits two women
died from the Stampede and a third woman
remains hospitalized in critical
condition seven other people were
treated for non-threatening Life
injuries glorilla said in a tweet that
she's quote devastated and heartbroken
for the victims in Sunday's incident on
Monday local officials held a press
conference to provide more details on
the investigation
there are some reports that shots were
heard causing the crowd to panic
but that has not been confirmed we do
not have any evidence of gunshots being
fired or of anyone being shot or stabbed
at the scene
investigators from Patrol section
investigations are currently assigned to
this to investigate the incident to not
only determine what happened but to
bring accountability to those who were
culpable for last night's tragedy
we are hearing many reports of potential
causes including possibly crowd size
shots fired
pepper spray and other contributing
factors
our investigators are interviewing
surviving victims
other concert goers
security
and anyone else that has potential
information as to what led to the
tragedy last night
we are working with the city Fire
Marshal's Office to help determine the
number of concert goers related to the
capacity of the venue
in addition we are working with various
other licensing agencies such as code
enforcement the New York state liquor
Authority
incorporation Council to verify
compliance with regulatory safety
measures and to hold those who were not
in compliance
accountable for their actions
sir this is a terrible terrible
situation I gotta ask criminal charges
imminent I think it's possible I don't
think think it's probably you have to
find a person who failed to assess the
risk now you could pin it on some one
person and then you could have criminal
negligence and of course someone died
here so you could have criminally
negligent homicide in New York and it's
a classy felony and it's one to five
years but there are just so many people
involved here I think it would be very
difficult to point to one person
obviously whoever is in control of the
crowd is one person they could point the
finger to I see this more as a civil
case versus a criminal case but if law
enforcement really wants to send a
message they will look for that one
person who really was in charge and
should have been able to control that
scene and obviously fail to do so in
this instance well Brian that's the
question right who's at fault it feels
like everybody's going to be pointing
the finger at everybody else for what
ultimately happened all right so Jesse
if you and our viewers are familiar of
the whole Spider-Man meme where they're
all pointing at each other that's
basically going to happen in a civil
case whoever was running the venue is
going to to point the finger at who
owned the venue and who let people in is
it a question of did they have too many
people come in did they serve them too
much alcohol did they conform to the
rules and regulations of having this
many people at a venue you can look at
the alcohol servers the venue owners the
people who promoted uh the the event you
could probably even if we've seen in the
past go and attack the people who
actually were performing at the venue
that's an option as well
and all those people who are going to
have their fingers pointed at them in
order to minimize their liability
they're going to start pointing fingers
at other people who are also getting
their fingers pointed that's where the
whole Spider-Man pointing at the fingers
back and forth but really I think the
major question before we start asking
where fingers are going to get pointed
at is what is the cause is it a gunshot
is it pepper spray I mean that brings in
issues of itself but the people
obviously who brought any kind of
Contraband that sparked this Stampede
are going to be at fault but then of
course the question becomes again well
what was security like how are you able
to bring in these items so no matter who
we point the finger to I think there are
then going to be multiple people that we
continue to point the finger at and at
the end of the day I mean I'm more
criminal guy than I am civil I hope that
Terry's agreeing with me it all comes
down to us the biggest Pockets the
people who are victims here are going to
go after the people who have the most
money because that's how they're going
to find themselves whole at the end of
the day Brian Terry I think you wrapped
that up uh you know it's just a sad
situation but clearly it's just the
beginning of something next Brian Terry
thank you both so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on Long
crime daily we're going to see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America